with the release of XCOM to Firaxis
games is bringing numerous changes to
its turn-based strategy formula in ways
both big and small
one of the major additions is the new
Sai operative class a soldier archetype
that uses the aliens mind-control powers
against them so because of the class's
inherent power we've compiled a quick
list of the necessary research options
base facilities and training methods to
add the devastating Sai operative to
your XCOM roster first step kill a
sectoid you'll see these aliens early on
in the game and they'll often
mind-control your soldiers by killing
one of these aliens you'll unlock step 2
which is perform an autopsy on a sec toy
corpse this can easily be done in the
science lab at your Avenger Base and
should only take a few turns step 3 is
to research psionics in the research lab
much like the previous step this can be
done in the research lab and shouldn't
take more than a few days of in-game
time step 4 is to build a Sai lab
facility in one of the open spaces in
your base by adding an engineer to the
building slot you should be able to
expedite the process as you fight more
battles once you have the scilab
facility completed you can move on to
step 5 which is to select a recruit to
teach the scythe unlike the normal
soldiers the Sai operative learns their
abilities through studying so as long as
they don't get injured in battle you can
keep teaching them while also fighting
in individual firefights the last step
which is mainly to help the process
along is to station and engineer in the
Scilab to increase the recruits training
speed it's also important to note that
the Sai operative learns new skills at
random so your soldier might begin with
the inspire ability available but have
to learn aura soul fire and fuse and
subsequent turns so there you have it
the Sai operative is one of the many
changes present in the fantastic XCOM -
and especially in late-game missions
should help you overcome the alien
threat
I'll definitely get that